[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I am our Bernard holy [ __ ] it's
been a red-hot minutes it's been able to
do this man I was off in Florida for a
few weeks working on Kilroy Was Here but
mark has been living the [ __ ] fat
life of his successful TV show writers
that write well they don't big castle
rock which Mark has written on has
finally dropped as the kids say it has
and the time since we've been back six
episodes of the show have been released
into the wild
including my episode which was last week
I saw the I don't know if there's a
tweet or an Instagram he put up of the
title card with your name and the credit
you were super proud give it up for a
man he got it
what what's it like when people like
what you make it's been a long time
since I've felt that it's a bit like a
warm bath I think you know I remember
kind of swimming a little bit and get
old and looks and crannies out but now
it's it has been the most surreal
[ __ ] like week and a half
why explain Phillip ah so the show
dropped and the reviews have been pretty
strong and the response that I've gotten
online was pretty great the show got
picked up for a second season
oh these are two of God's all wrong so
that's great and then the same week they
announced that the show that I'm
currently working on Treadstone got its
full series order at USA oh [ __ ] man
you're a magic [ __ ] a magic totem man
imagine charm I'm just saying man he'll
rub me for luck it seems to be working
feels like the move and you guys paid to
get in so
that's fantastic what is who what's the
nicest compliment or the [ __ ]
highlight like what's the thing that
defines the experience now for you since
the show has come out the thing that
defines experience was Shane black
tweeting how much he likes the show the
[ __ ] seriously the director of Kiss Kiss
Bang Bang D and Iron Man 3 kiss kiss
clang clang oh [ __ ] man I got to
interview him at uh San Diego for the
IMT because he's got that predator movie
coming out and [ __ ] not Bloom ups I love
his bork he [ __ ] complimented you he
did he was like Castle Rock is the real
deal as that gets actual for real horror
everybody should watch it I was like
[ __ ] can't do that to me
because I would start to cry now and
like Stephen King [ __ ] tweeted about
it that might have been contractually
obligated I don't know what did well he
also gets paid the more people watch it
that's true yeah he's like I like this
as much as I liked Maximum Overdrive
What did he say he said Stephen King
said look past the Easter eggs and
you'll see real character based horror
or something to that effect are there
are many Easter eggs there's there's
there's nods to things there's like
little newspaper clipping stuck in my
Cujo seriously yeah yeah one of the
characters names is is everybody up to
date does anybody give a [ __ ] if I spoil
one thing you're not I know but ok so
Jackie the the female character played
by Jane levy her last name is Torrence
what yes and so she's the niece of Jack
Torrance and
and Andre Andre Holland plays a
character and Henry beavers got a son so
much name is Wendell and so who's Wendy
Jack and Wendy Oh wife I said Wendell
his name is Wendell but the whole idea
is that we have a kid one day well know
that Jack Jack Torrence lady Jack
Torrence will have a relationship with
man Wendell and that relationship will
go badly how's that time went Jack and
Wendy Wendell Wendy right so it's a
reference to them but it's not the real
Jack the real them well [ __ ] your show
then and that was too long have you had
me right in the Palmer House my god it's
all connected and you're like no it's
not at all yeah but that's cute that's
kind of nice I mean so there's lots of
little bits lots a little [ __ ] in there
that kind of rewards the deep King
reader but so his point was like don't
worry about that like his point his
tweet was to people like me it was just
like Google like hey man what about Cujo
does Cujo show up he's like don't worry
about that they're making a good show
yeah well if you look closely there was
a puppy walking down a ship a street a
st. Bernard now I'm just [ __ ] with
you what it could work man oh man [ __ ]
you no that's awesome good for you so
Treadstone being picked up that's a that
means did you guys only do a pilot what
was going on you don't even shot
anything you know they wrote a pilot
script that got the network's [ __ ]
excited and then they opened up a room
and we've been working for about a month
and a half and then we finally got the
you get to keep getting paid email of
you got picked up for the full season oh
sure yeah
what's that email like it's pretty great
man yeah I'd imagine a dude who didn't
work for most of last year to suddenly
like have a job and two jobs once right
after the other
I know dovetailing look what happens
when Castle Rock starts up again ah
we'll see we'll see there could you be
an all coy you look last year I didn't
work now you're like I'll pick one we'll
see what happens
that's awesome plus cuz well he's saying
that cuz he's got some [ __ ] in the
hopper man there's other [ __ ] in hopper
he talked about did you talk about yeah
you talked about movement yeah your
project you didn't say what it was
but there's the thing happening there's
the thing happened yes and now we're
starting to talk about directors for the
thing that would happen all right so
that means it's happening maybe in a
very positive way I mean we and I just
having a fun conversation that we can't
tell anybody else about except that we
are so but i legit did not know about
that
that [ __ ] Castlerock [ __ ] like you
kept that quiet and anything yeah and I
asked him the whole time here Meaghan I
was like tell me some [ __ ] he's like nah
we ain't doing that that's how we keep
the relationship fresh
I just withhold some [ __ ] and then drop
it on you eight months later yeah I I
got something apropos of nothing imma
jump to this because I felt it in my
pocket tell me please I got a belated
birthday gift
last August 2nd was my birthday I turned
48 we wouldn't had a Film Festival out
of New Jersey a vulgar thon in the town
of Red Bank and stuff so since I've been
and then I went down to Florida and shot
Kilroy Was here for 10 days which was
excellent
Chris Jericho came down a lot of people
acted in it Betty aberlin was in it
Betty aberlin who was on Mister Rogers
neighborhood she's been a number of our
films she crushed it came out and did
parts she crushed it
anemic Elvis's daughter Daisy came out
to the park she crushed it Ralph Garman
from Hollywood babble-on came out to the
part he [ __ ] crushed it then Chris
Jericho came out and did a part and not
only did he act but we asked him like
the his character is a streamer an
online streamer called the Gator chaser
so the premise of the short it's you
know a Kilroy Was here is kind of like
Creepshow there's a framing device that
sets up your monster or whatever [ __ ]
and then five four or five separate
stories throughout the movie and stuff
little chapter stories and anthology so
in in in putting that together [ __ ] why
did I jump off on that Oh so one of the
segments this gator chaser thing doesn't
look like the rest because it looks like
at one point it cuts to the to an iPhone
shot and clearly it's somebody streaming
as an eldership
so you wouldn't have your DP necessarily
shooter your cam
I guess you could but we were like
wouldn't it make more sense for the
actor to shoot themselves like right on
a [ __ ] phone and stuff all low-budge
so Chris Jericho came out now in like
middle of the [ __ ] night in Sarasota
where it's like 110 degrees [ __ ]
humidity and every bug crawling up your
[ __ ] sphincter so he came out that
was nice enough and he had a bunch of
dialogue not even dialogue monologue to
say because he's just talking to the
audience it's not there it was a bunch
of [ __ ] to memorize and then on top of
that I was like you've got to shoot your
own performance as well here's the
camera so like the difficulty level was
very high and he [ __ ] executed his
execute he elevated he was [ __ ]
awesome I was impressed but it's one
thing to be good as an actor it's
another thing to like [ __ ] carry
another job completely altogether that
you did not know you were gonna do when
he got to set so that was a real [ __ ]
revelation stuff so I had a great time
shooting down there then I came home and
I got to open a bunch of [ __ ] that
people send me for my birthday this is
what I got from DC the ultimate DC
membership it's a card man that puts me
into that DC Universe app and I get to
kind of check it out in advance and [ __ ]
a sweet gift but I bought this [ __ ]
already I don't know why they thought I
would have waited you know what I'm
saying like they're like I know we'll
get him something you can't possibly
have the DC at the moment they announced
the DC app I was like [ __ ] you take all
my money I'm already in on this [ __ ] it
ain't you know I guess I'm gonna test it
out don't turn around
cuz maybe they know that I bought one no
like well if we give him a black card
happy birthday idiot you know
but uh you know I was I was very it was
delightful and I was very pleased and
stuff but at the same time I'm like well
I I don't know if you guys know this but
I host a show called fat man on Batman
like I'm a fan I'm in the bag for this
[ __ ] maybe we don't remind them because
then they'll sue us for [ __ ] using
Batman in the new from a sooner or later
we have to change the name of the show I
hate saying that but it went a lot
longer than I ever thought it would I
always assumed sooner or later Warner
Brothers would be like stop it but you
know but so far so good but now it's
just a series of tweets on the internet
of people being like it's false
advertising cuz you're not [ __ ] fat
anymore I disagree I could show them my
shirt off and then they'll be like
nevermind keep calling it that keep
calling with that but still we might
have to one day come up with a different
name what would you call it if you could
have picked a name the same [ __ ]
thing we do you're remembering that when
we started as fat man I'm Batman
it was literally [ __ ] talking about
Batman every episode
now clearly like every once in a while
we're like hey Batman is still around
and [ __ ] so what would you called the
show based on what it is now what it's
become right here in our home which by
the way I didn't announce the scum and
villainy Cantina right here in Hollywood
Boulevard
put your hands ago this is the folks at
home know you're real
not Cosmo has been working on that [ __ ]
for like a month
that charms me and delighted oh I am too
didn't we were walking in I was like oh
my god my childhood so some who okay
later on for sure all right no end of
the night you got it yeah but no not now
sit the [ __ ] down
no no no no no we were just saying it's
weird that you yelled out at this point
of the show nobody ever does that and
stuff so yeah you're still doing it so
she's just a hands day here we go moving
forward I don't know oh yeah a new name
cuz it's done you name it so based on
the show recording here this incarnation
of what the show is what we call it I
don't know I mean utility belt was cool
for a while like we thought about that
although what's still Batman adjacent
that's so [ __ ] weird
I always thought spoilers which is an
old show that we used to do on Hulu
because technically it's what we do here
it's true but I don't know I don't I
don't know the recycle bin because we
just read [ __ ] that I pulled off the
internet that everybody else already
knows this secret recipe I don't know
good thing we don't have to come up with
it tonight but one day we might have to
sooner or later the good folks at DC are
gonna be like look man this has gone on
long enough
you don't own Batman you know and then
[ __ ] we have to come up with another
name but that's not tonight we'll
workshop it yeah
and also we'll take some suggestions
from the folks at home not right now but
but later
anybody got any suggestions man hashtag
what would you cash tag it man bat less
fat man bad rogues gallery that's
[ __ ] good man it's not that yeah
that's tough to spell
there'll be a lot of Rouge gallery going
on stuff I'm getting a lot of makeup
tips
hashtag fat man no more ooh sounds more
dramatic than it is I like it though
yeah right because that's you'll that
hashtag might play in the real world
people be like oh okay we're done good
thanks moving on maybe that's what we
call it man no more of the podcast come
on I'm sure there's a better one keep
getting me there and then just [ __ ]
let it down Rose gallery no that's me
I'm a tease like Jesus man
all right enough about all that do we
have news we have some news this is the
part of the show ladies and gentlemen
we're mr. mark Barnard and aggregates
all the news that matters to folks like
us and we read the Internet's news give
it up for mark he found the news hi
Spence so much time on this you guys you
don't [ __ ] know it's like 25 minutes
today yeah I couldn't give her the full
half-hour but I think we got some good
[ __ ] hey did you know that Brendan
Fraser is gonna be in Doom Patrol what
yes
as the chief as robot man cliff Steele
oh [ __ ] really yeah man but wait is he
going to be a guy in makeup no he's
gonna do the voice ah and he's they're
gonna shoot some flashback [ __ ] so
before he gets all mad metallus eyes so
when he's cliff but they got it he's
doing the voice I got another dude to
wear the suit and they got another dude
I think for the CG stuff I'm sure
they're gonna be doing well so the suit
is a motion-capture thing I know so yeah
yeah Wow they're spending some money on
that [ __ ]
they'd have to the Doom Patrol is a
concept that even more so than Titans
lends itself to the fantastic you're
talking about- man you're talking about
the lady that gets all [ __ ] huge and
[ __ ] like that robot man the cheapest
effect I guess is chief right he's just
a dude in a chair and stuff and this is
crazy Jane cyborg yeah sure how soon
before they do Monsieur Mallah and the
brain
if you don't know the Doom Patrol one of
their arch villains is a giant gorilla
the name Monsieur Mallah and he carries
around a brain in a jar called the brain
it's so [ __ ] wacky DC created this I
think before marvel before Stan created
the x-men correct they were there like a
minute beforehand if I remember my comic
book history correctly and if you look
at both concepts like Professor X's in a
wheelchair Niles Caulder is in a
wheelchair of the chief you know they're
there
misfits as well just like the x-men were
kind of misfits and stuff similar
concept so you can go great places with
the Doom Patrol man I look forward to in
a big bad way and that's a good cast and
he's [ __ ] wonderful what the [ __ ] was
going on with everybody creating hyper
intelligent gorillas was there like
something in the water at that moment DC
specialized rod [ __ ] Misha Ramallah
like Marvel's got like two or three of
them yeah did they think we loved super
smart monkeys this is my my theory and I
could be wrong somebody could easily
disprove it depending on when these
characters created maybe it was the
Planet of the Apes influence yeah yet a
series of successful sci-fi movies with
with talking apes and stuff so they were
like oh [ __ ] this plays in comics like
if you look at Marvel in the 70s they
followed every [ __ ] trend there was
including Satanism remember Satan got
real big in the 70s people like have you
met that devil and there was like the
Church of Satan [ __ ] and Marvel was like
we're and they had you know it was an
exorcist it done well and [ __ ] like that
The Omen Rosemary's Baby Ave wrote like
the Satanist handbook it's like people
really discover the devil in the late
60s or early 70s and marvel [ __ ] like
created the son of Satan character agent
hellström yes like they went big into
and stuff and now you know now they
don't talk about it as much I guess like
yeah we don't do the Satan thing anymore
sighs II bought us we got I got cute
chicks eight Anna we can kind of still
do that every now and again yeah I guess
that would be my guess as to where the
talking gorilla stuff came from plus
it's just if you're making a comic book
like particularly if you were making a
comic book pre-internet pre of
television pre cable TV and stuff like
you know when they were originally
selling calm
most kids and this is the only thing
kids really had to do other than play
with that giant circle with a stick that
you see in [ __ ] old timey [ __ ]
cartoons and [ __ ] and like pick up
sticks
pick that [ __ ] up or pick a game
elaborate [ __ ] shows like The Little
Rascals and [ __ ] like that and make
money off it and stuff you know back
then showing a kid a talking gorilla I'm
sure they were like oh my god could you
imagine what will ever be better than
this and then one day you're like the
matrix [ __ ] won't let that blow
your mind but III that is a great
casting call great casting choice I was
already in the bag for that series but
that makes me go like oh that's clever
that's good really smart excellent use
of Brendan Fraser which we haven't got
nearly enough of that is true though
are you a James Bond fan um where's your
bond love fall a scale of one to ten is
it double-oh-seven
I'm worthless my father was a big James
Bond fan sand naturally that makes me
something of a James Bond fan because he
took me he took me all the movies but he
loved when new Bond movies came out and
bond was like the
demarcation line a bar by which all
other movies were judged when I was a
little kid until Raiders of the Lost Ark
when I went to see Raiders of the Lost
Ark like once see with my father and I
came back and I was telling my friend
Ernie about it nobody else had seen it
nobody else was talking about going to
say it and I was like I saw this movie
with this guy and he's played by Han
Solo it was Harrison Ford man and this
guy he plays Indiana Jones he's better
than bond man like that was the nearest
parallel I can find and Ernie want to
fight me he's like no one's better than
bond and I was like trust me you'll see
this [ __ ] and he saw it and he did agree
with me he's like he's an American James
Bond and [ __ ] and jingoistic Lee we
embraced it Indiana Jones together so I
like I like bond some more than others
and stuff I'm like Ralph Garman loves
James Bond I can tell you to leave it
yeah it's it's not quite like the star
old Star Trek movies where I'm like oh I
love all the even number one
I like a lot of James Bond movies but
not all of them well Raiders I'm not
sure if you know this you probably do
though Spielberg wanted to make a James
Bond movie once he desperately wanted to
make a James Bond movie
anyway they wouldn't let him because
there had been a rule maybe still in
place that only British directors could
director of James Bond movie and by the
guy there's one lee.toma hoary who made
one of this shittier Tomorrow Never Dies
yeah yeah is the world who's New Zealand
which i think is kind of technically a
British territory but everybody else has
been British and that has been a
long-standing rule and Spielberg
desperately wanted to make it and they
wouldn't let him so he made Raiders Lost
Ark Wow and the [ __ ] tagline was like
better than Bond bigger than something
else that said that's a yeah yeah I
thought that was my original thought eh
you said it somewhere I could point
attorney to the poster say right on the
poster yeah and Quentin wanted to make a
Bond movie for a long time I heard that
he wanted to do Casino Royale yeah and
that's when they wound up making scene
and I actually made it kind of dark like
not the usual light fare so is that the
first Daniel Craig one that was well
where gets rammed in the nuts with the
rope yes it's about as dark as it gets
man sit here swap the best part is every
James Bond movie they scream at Royal
Albert Hall I think in the UK and the
Queen was present for Casino Royale
because I think she always [ __ ] goes
to these things and so there's a moment
where the Queen of England is watching
James Bond get wailed in the [ __ ]
nuts
- it's a game what's more for the cheap
seats
I'm sure she's like Oh bother they have
lost another director Danny Boyle we're
supposed to direct James dude he directs
one before this was supposed to be his
first one Oscar winner Danny Boyle who
did it prior to him Sam Oh Sam Mendes
yeah oh yes that's right this was gonna
be Danny Boyle's first yes out he's out
why on creative differences what does
that mean my guess is he wanted to do
[ __ ] that the broccoli family didn't
want him to do and I don't know what
that is totally and I think there's also
an open question about because Daniel
Craig this is his last one he said that
for the last two or three whether it's
been a big groundswell of like why the
[ __ ] is it yourself and not James Bond
already yeah
plus there's a tweet he put up last week
yeah he was like Elba L hid yourself
right some are like know he's always why
was there yes still still I haven't seen
that yeah
no it's because you know the Internet
man yeah they will always find a way to
[ __ ] on the good I guess I don't do the
entire internet because the Internet I
saw it seemed very high on the idea most
of us are because we know that it's it's
just [ __ ] Elva and he'd be amazing
and everything but some regardless
though Daniel Craig is doing one more
he's doing one more I thought the last
one he was just like I'm [ __ ] through
I'm done with this [ __ ] and they were
like chit Ching and he was like one more
time who do you think I should take it
over if it has to be a British director
Chris Nolan yeah I mean of course but
that's isn't that like [ __ ] taking a
Lamborghini to go to the convenience
store you know like he's he's a film
genius he's yeah but he did Batman
Batman as a ladder to get to the to the
genius level
you're right yeah that's worked
franchise and as a kid I'm sure as every
other [ __ ] British kid has like James
Bond was the hero like James Bond of
Doctor Who and I don't know if he's
gonna do [ __ ] TV and Cardiff so maybe
I guess he just does James Bond it's
Ben's
I told me I would like to see a Chris
Nolan James Bond movie what that would
look like a lot of spinning tops and
[ __ ] like that bullets that never fall
totally whole movie happens in Reverse I
wonder if George Miller qualifies who
has an Australian does George Miller
qualifying bigos I would watch the [ __ ]
excellent pull out of James Bond a fury
road yeah yeah that's true man that gave
us Mad Max everything because it's
George Miller time
all right well [ __ ] sad to see Danny
Boyle go but like he usually does
interesting flicks every time out so
it's not like he's heard something else
to do himself as Oscar be like what
should I do next
that's right he's got one yeah I mean
[ __ ] dude if I was him I like I made
Trainspotting I'd be cruising on that
for the rest of my life I made clerks
and I'm cruising on that for the rest of
my life well the Parker made
Trainspotting like you don't have to
lift a finger for the rest of his life
that's a beautiful perfect [ __ ] move
what he also made Trainspotting too
which is a worthy follow-up yeah it's
true he is gonna ride in the Train isn't
he but that's a worthy follow-up I like
that movie but yeah as far as I'm
concerned he's he can cruise in neutral
for the rest of his career if he likes
but he never seems to do that it always
swings for the fences God knoweth why
work smarter not harder I said what's
next ah do you we didn't get to talk
about Ruby Rose being cast as Batwoman
that's awesome I I just saw her in
shark movie I want to see the meg
yesterday you like the Meg I saw her in
that shark movie they got my money isn't
that enough did jason statham kick a
shark in the face no why would you make
a movie with Jason Statham where he
doesn't kick a [ __ ] shark in the face
he does something else I ain't gonna
spoil it but how many people saw the mag
put your hands together real quick Wow
it's [ __ ] huge they made a lot of
money but yeah there's a me and the kid
were excited this was a daddy-daughter
date like I was like talking or from
Florida and she was like you can't go
see the Meg without me I was like I will
never go see the Meg without you I love
you kiddo and this was something we look
forward to doing together and we even
bought like gale Jen's mom with us
Harley's Nana all three of us go see the
mag man yeah
tough [ __ ] but he doesn't punch a shark
Lee he does something in the third act
with a shark there's a [ __ ] it then why
would I be complaining about that movie
I would have opened with I saw the most
amazing movie of all time no wonder it
made a hundred million dollars Jason
Statham [ __ ] a shark and some drama
quitting the milk business because
there's nothing left to do man but yeah
it was the trailer was amazing promised
a lot of shark does your arm wrestle the
shark no but he the way he takes it out
like I was really like profoundly
bothered by you know I should have been
that moment in the movies yeah kill that
[ __ ] shark we want it to die but the
way it takes it out I was like that's
[ __ ] horrible like that that's how
mean and [ __ ] shitty and did anyways
you leave it in in the bottom of a
shower and then put the hot water on it
for a long time until it dies like you
the way you
mark told the story couple episodes back
where he [ __ ] burned a gecko to death
executed a gecko for the [ __ ] lone
crime of being in his shower for sharing
my space it was like I don't want
cheaper insurance alright see yes Ruby
Rose cast as Batwoman for the news oh
goodness she was legit good in the shark
movie I think she'll make a great bad
woman
I think so too you know who doesn't let
me guess some of the Internet's yeah
yeah the internet came for her did they
have an opinion they had every opinion
saved good ones what I'm gonna I'm not
gonna bury the lead I actually know this
story a little bit and the things I find
confounding is that they were like hey
man you got if you're gonna hire
somebody to play Batwoman
you got to hire a lesbian to play bat
woman because bat woman's a lesbian and
stuff and you hired this Ruby Rose
instead and Ruby Rose jumped on Twitter
to be like I've been a lesbian since
I've been 14 right I'm out proud like
what I'm bad as lesbian as it gets
I've lost roles because I'm Leslie yeah
and so she left social media and not
because people were going LLL you're a
lesbian
because you're not lesbian enough to
play bat woman yes Wow it's getting to
be a thin tightrope out there isn't it
man
it really is you know the the only
upshot and it's not even upshot to that
story but the idea of being chased off
[ __ ] social media by bigots and and
you know hate mongers is killing Murray
Tran really an amazing story today in
the mid seventies just talking about you
know the level of internalized inward
self directed hate that you feel that
she felt as a person of color growing up
in this country especially as an Asian
woman of color and like just talking
about things like I my hardest to forget
Vietnamese that was because you know
kids would make fun of me like I speak
in perfect English and people would say
oh you have an exchange student you know
when [ __ ] born here like
and just that sense of wanting to erase
her own ethnicity because whiteness was
the default and how running away from
from Instagram and Twitter and social
media felt like a surrender to that
particular mindset that she found a
voice and she found herself and and it
was just beautiful it was beautiful
especially on the heels of [ __ ] like
that's happening apparently every like
three weeks yeah it's you know look I'd
be certainly I can't speak to her
experience but you know I for most of my
career because I had a because of I was
Silent Bob or whatever the [ __ ] a lot of
people hey big guy hey big guy call a
big guy and you're like oh I'm the big
guy cuz I'm in charge not realizing that
it's a very nice way of calling you fat
guy and then when Southwest Airlines had
my guy kicked off the plane to fat to
fly that felt like the whole world
knowing that I was [ __ ] fat like they
all did but like that felt like oh my
god everyone knows like suddenly out of
the Eye of Sauron fell me I fell on me
and it was horrifying man to be made to
feel like the other and I'd enjoyed
inclusion for so long and you know yeah
I'm [ __ ] white person so I'm included
[ __ ] everywhere but unfortunately I
was also ostracized for a long portion
of my life because I didn't look kind of
[ __ ] normal and it sucks to be made to
feel that way
closest I ever came to jumping off of
Twitter forever was during to fat to fly
because there was a like legit fat hate
not just like you know [ __ ] stop
crying or whatever but like disgust for
like I hate having to sit next to
[ __ ] like you on a plane and blow it
like it was just really [ __ ] weird
and I so I've tasted a little bit of
that [ __ ] she tasted a universe full of
[ __ ] hey and still had the composure
to come back and write a really [ __ ]
beautiful piece something beautiful did
come from that horrible experience do
you know if she's gonna come back to
social media I don't know my father and
not that like [ __ ] social media but I
bet you you're more productive not
having
one more thing to do I wish that I could
get rid of it I wish I could quit you
yeah but I can you know and I think also
she was probably you know I speaking for
her which I shouldn't do but the fact
that this piece came out the same
weekend after the weekend the crazy rich
Asians opened to like you know twenty
eight million dollars which covers its
budget which like raptures reviews which
you know the first mainstream Hollywood
movie to feature predominately Asian
cast and look close yeah which is
ridiculous in almost every way you can
measure a thing as ridiculous yes it
qualifies so yeah maybe just the
confluence of events were enough to sort
of is a [ __ ] it like why I don't need to
hide Who I am anymore I don't need to
hate myself for who I am anymore [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it
amen so hey did you watch Veronica Mars
on TV I not only did i watch is that the
most abrupt yeah what a [ __ ] left
turn hit that was there's no way I'd
pull out of that [ __ ] die if I'm not
she just kinda it's not a good dive
there's a real moment nothing wrong with
that yes I watched not only did I watch
it I was on Veronica Mars season two
yeah I was dude guess what I played a
convenience store clerk so it was a real
[ __ ] stretch but yeah I got to be on
the show but Dan Etheridge is a friend
of mine he's a producer on was the
producer on that show it is it's coming
back he he told me a long time ago and
I've been sitting on that information
for a while which proves that like you
can tell me [ __ ] yeah he told me a while
back each I don't want some will I don't
want to say anything that hasn't been
said what does it say okay it's looking
like it's giving in on the chance on
Hulu they're gonna do another season
exactly what I heard keep going on with
Kristen Bell who's going to split time
between a good place and I hurt my first
question was like how is she gonna do
that she's a right now show they're like
they're very amenable and and she wants
to do this in a big bad way I don't know
her very well I know we're a little bit
over the years and stuff
she's a from what I've gathered a
lovely person but she has been so
[ __ ] supportive of that show she
after frozen she easily could have been
like Veronica who but she still [ __ ]
brings it back to life which i think is
incredibly admirable I like that man she
sticks by that show that show first
season of Veronica Mars if you've never
seen it is this fine a [ __ ] first
season of a series as ever was a
fantastic [ __ ] mystery it roped you
in you know they had just enough
mythology at the end of each episode to
kind of keep you going with the main
mystery of involving Lilly Kane and
stuff but incredibly well acted great
diverse characters and stuff beautiful
father/daughter relationship one that
you don't really see on TV that often
such a great [ __ ] show so I'm glad to
hear that it's getting another I hope
they do that until she [ __ ] dies I
hope they turn this [ __ ] into Murder She
Wrote when when she's like 80 years old
and she's still doing V Mars and [ __ ]
because that they need a guy to work the
convenience store God willing I'll still
be around I'll come out and do it but I
I'm glad they're getting do it again
yeah there's no word yet on how many
episodes when it's gonna come back I
know I know all that [ __ ] but I can't
reveal it well [ __ ] it why am I telling
you [ __ ] you already know there I'm glad
if a brother off man no you wouldn't
[ __ ] even tell me about Cujo alright
[Music]
what Michael Winslow's here Cujo okay
let's do a cop car what a hookup what
else you got
let me see hey you know they were gonna
make a Star Trek for or at 14 however
that works on the numbering yeah they
were gonna make a new Star Trek movie
they were where Chris Hemsworth was
gonna reprise his role as George Kirk
which I was all for he played Kirk's dad
in the first few minutes of the JJ Star
Trek which was a fantastic [ __ ] scene
yeah even if you're like I like that
Star Trek there's too much running
around they don't act like the
characters and [ __ ] oh lens flares yeah
if it's if you're in that camp you got
to admit that opening seeing Kirk born
in flames is [ __ ] brilliant and him
being born as his father sacrifice his
life and [ __ ] like a built-in bias
against
like all of that [ __ ] man was like I
don't I don't give a [ __ ] if you don't
if you like the original incarnation I'm
not taking that away from you you got to
admit that's really good [ __ ]
storytelling totally and and to get that
scene with Roose Greenwood who says like
your father was Captain of a starship
for two minutes and that's on you see oh
my god such a good scene I dare you dare
you better [ __ ] that's good ain't no
wonder they gave him Star Wars man he's
good all right so yeah hands where
they're supposed to come back he was
supposed to hold time-travel Luke T 2
which would have been awesome because he
could have teamed up with his dad and
[ __ ] maybe saved his dad from the
[ __ ] sacrifice you know whatever you
time-travel maybe Wales were involved
because it's Star Trek who knows hope so
it's not gonna happen why money sorry
that's how much they need I got like 20
bucks because I really want to say they
should happen I think it'd be fun what's
the money thing they're not getting paid
and the problem is is that both Chris
Pine and Chris Hemsworth are giant
[ __ ] movie stars all right so what
are they even that Max 20 million apiece
mm-hmm and let's say you get him to do
come on boys like will you take this on
the back we're both Chris's we can all
just [ __ ] play game how about this 10
against 10
10 up front 10 million bucks and then
10% of back-end first-dollar gross
there's I've done the deal call them up
make it all better make it all happen
make it so then he's got like everybody
[ __ ] else in that cast who also needs
to get paid and it turns out that those
movies were never like giganto
box-office hits they all did well they
all made money but none of them made
over 350 400 million worldwide right
yeah so they saw their counter counting
pennies there are healthy performers but
they're not [ __ ] Avengers movies
right and so you're not gonna back up
the money to be fair nothing's of [ __ ]
Avengers yeah but so what this is their
agents gone now we want more I think so
I mean is it possible that they'll go
back to the table and [ __ ] negotiate
and make it happen hopefully maybe I
think Star Trek really has no choice man
they can't recast Chris Pine is
fantastic like it was it was
Chansey bringing another kirk into the
world they found like the one guy who
can pull it off where it doesn't sound
like an impression but it totally omage
is an entire [ __ ] body of work in a
character so you know you got to bring
him back
maybe you know you let go of the dad
storyline if he can't get Emsworth to
come down a little bit but you know you
can't do those Star Trek's without that
Kirk he was great although there's also
the Quentin Tarantino Star Trek that he
was developing which I don't know what
that story was but it seems to have been
in tandem development so probably would
not have featured the JJ cast is that
right I don't think it was gonna I think
it was supposed to be some totally
different altered splinter timeline and
whatever alright so if you tell me I
can't have Chris Pine and Chris
Hemsworth if I can't have Chris squared
teaming up in a trek movie but I can
have Quentin Tarantino doing a trek
movie happily samuel l.jackson I don't
care if he oh my god holy [ __ ] I want
you to fire a photon torpedo right off
that [ __ ] sacks
I want these [ __ ] Klingons off
this [ __ ] ship be me to [ __ ] up
I don't care if he cast children I would
watch that movie like if it was like
Bugsy Malone version of Star Trek and
Quentin's just like I cast kids because
I thought it'd be cool you know you know
but that's that's a shame I hope they
work out the money thing yeah I can play
mediator if they want I'll be like come
on and it all one wants to see this and
they're like their agent that's you know
the problem here is agents are involved
if I could just like get rid of their
agents and talk sense to those actors I
bet you they'd want to do it because it
sounds like a [ __ ] fun movie but you
know somebody out there is like note I
got to get paid these are the dollars
they're gonna last them into the years
of their life
Buffalo blah so uh you know I'm all for
people getting paid but that's a good an
idea to leave behind there but if your
point is they don't make enough money to
support that kind of financial decision
then you know maybe they somebody they
got to meet in the middle man they got
to boldly go where no man has gone
before I hope so because I like that guy
and I think that idea was a really good
idea last story did you in your while
you were down in Florida making movies
did you see what the film Academy
decided to do about the Oscars no not
invite me yet again they decided to
create a new category called best
popular film well yeah because ratings
are down the last Oscar telecast was the
worst so there'll be a Best Picture yes
and the best picture that everyone likes
correct I came in I guess like or you
could just you know I mean because like
in that configuration there's no way in
the world they're gonna make anybody
watch that show make one more person
watch that show like oh [ __ ] they they
nominated the Avengers like you can get
the Avengers to show up and present
awards and that does like didn't a few
of them come to the last Oscars yeah
they always come I don't think that I I
mean look they could do whatever they
want with their super fun happy Club but
I don't think that makes one extra
person want to watch the Oscars I mean
what do you am I wrong what they will
tell you is that the Oscars have its
best ratings ever when like Fellowship
of the Ring was nominated in one I'm
sorry when when
Return of the King won best bit great so
that's when on every year and then
people will watch it over and over again
Titanic won like everybody [ __ ]
watched they would they will tell you
that when a giant blockbuster wins then
more people show up to see if it'll win
and they'll say that when the artist
wins and Hurt Locker wins nobody gives a
[ __ ]
well I did I mean look I they could do
whatever they want
I'm not telling people how to run their
[ __ ] show but isn't the point of the
Academy Awards
long before television was involved to
honor the buck and best and brightest in
the field that who belonged to the
Academy what does that have to do with
well more people watch the show when
[ __ ] a good movie get wins an award
like why does that matter it only
matters to the Academy cuz that is the
one way they really make money is by
selling the rights to that to ABC
insurance and more and selling ads
during the telecast and making that cash
but my fear is that in the same way that
like buting the beast was nominated for
Best Picture yes like just straight up
[ __ ] this was one of the best movies
made this year yeah
and then when they didn't qualify it as
an animated film was nominated that
happened like 105 they were like [ __ ]
that we don't want to give one of these
slots to a [ __ ] cartoon let's make a
separate category for them to have to
play in their little ghetto wise cartoon
corner and so now there is never going
to be you know the Dark Knight up for
Best Picture there's never gonna be Mad
Max fury road or for Best Picture
there's never gonna be get out up for
Best Picture if they're going to now say
well movies people like get to go over
here we're gonna reward the [ __ ] that
nobody saw what some of which is
beautiful and lovely and glorious but if
it's all going to be a bunch of indie
movies that were released in December
24th to make the cut off and that
doesn't seem to be what the Oscars are
about and also are there number of award
shows for what people like like the
People's Choice even the Golden Globes
seems to be more what people like or
whatever why is the Oscars won for some
reason they're still in MTV and they
still have the Movie Awards do that yeah
yeah I mean I'm not believe me I'm mad
and I'm not like we got to stop this but
it just seems like I don't think that
fixes their problem like at the end of
the day sometimes more people watch the
Oscars than not like you know if you and
I guess like they've got 10 slots for
Best Picture now correct which they
added a couple years ago to for this
[ __ ] that room is to be like to
include movies that are a little more
mainstream I don't know does not
where the would Black Panther Black
Panther I mean it will qualify for the
regular [ __ ] Oscars cause this
doesn't take effect till 2020 so it will
be a Best Picture nominee in 2021 that
movie would be a best popular picture
and how much weight is the category
gonna be given against the Best Picture
category if I had to guess it will come
right after Best Foreign Film so not a
lot of weight it's not a ton of weight
like because it's not the big award but
it's the lets front loaded in the in the
telecast to make sure people [ __ ]
show up and call it quits
hey man again their club their rules
they could do whatever they want i I
don't think that really helps you know
short-sided
it feels a little bit yeah oh well what
a weird sad story to end on sorry are
you making a comment I am making a comic
book so I've talked about on a few shows
mr. mark Miller over at Miller world
asked me they were bring him back hit
girl in a standalone book of her own
with a bunch of different artists and
writers taking on the characters thank
you and so he asked me to do an arc and
and I said oh well god that'd be fun and
stuff because I loved the movie I loved
the comic books as well so I wrote it
and and four issues comes out in January
and they just announced the artists and
we had the artists on here not so long
ago standing over there is pernil who
designed the DC superhero girls and I'm
kind of like proud of this I you know I
I mean I don't know if I'm proud but I
put it forward I was like I love her art
hire her she's the first woman who to
draw Hit Girl like who'll be published
to draw her crown I think they hired
another woman to draw it as well but I
think for Neil's run comes out before
the other one man so I was like yay like
we got somebody on the book that
it's like a woman you know doing
hit-girl makes sense felt a little weird
that I was writing it and and there was
going to be a guy drawn instead so I I'm
so happy for her because I love her
style I loved what she did with the DC
superhero girls and stuff and I know
what the scripts are about I don't know
why Mark Miller was out there he said
something about like this is set in
Hollywood and he was indicating like
she's going after sexual predators
that's not the story I wrote at all just
for the record it's hit it's hit girl
it's called the golden rage of Hollywood
and the idea is that she comes to
Hollywood in the first issue she finds
out that she finds a book about her like
a crime true fiction crime novel called
heretofore Hit Girl
and on the bottom of the back cover it
says soon to be a major motion picture
so she goes to Hollywood to stop it I
just stole the plot from Jay and Silent
Bob strike back which when I made that
movie everyone's like this is a comic
book movie I was like alright well this
is a comic book and so I used it for
that it's fun it's good times and stuff
but I think the story which is very you
know madcap and violent as those tours
tend to be is gonna look real good in
her style her style is very like it's
Disney as she was in the very Disney
style so I've seen like not only some of
her sketches but she sent me a page of
artwork and it's gorgeous so I can't
wait till people see that January it'll
be I am going to suck your dick a little
bit oh because the the thing that one of
the things I've always loved about you
is that you use your position and your
privilege to help elevate people who
would not normally get elevated to that
position explain so you in your podcast
universe in your gallery of York
allocated of stars yes it could have
easily been you know it started with you
and Scott could have been you and a
parade of you know dudes and beards but
you gave Ming a plat
to tell his story what his life is like
how his what his world is like how he
navigates existence yes Malcolm a voice
and gave him a leg up so people who
would not ordinarily know and that might
be a mistake but yes I did but like you
know if there's a part of your fan base
it doesn't know what it's like to be a
giant gay dude now they know you gave me
a platform and gets to talk to people
who would not ordinarily get to have
conversations with somebody like me
about this ship that I care about and
how I into the world and you're giving a
female artist a chance to do a book that
she absolutely would not have gotten the
chance to do before unless you had asked
for her like that is that is what
privilege can do it can help introduce
voices and people into a community that
would not ordinarily have so this is
that's definitely one way to look at the
prism I prefer the prism that you look
through but for me it's all selfish like
these people are talented like why
wouldn't I want to align myself with
these people you know and I'm saying
like whether it's you or [ __ ] Ralph
or Andy or like that's what I love about
this is the spod cast the network when I
first started a smart cast and we did
has been 11 years now 11 years in change
we've been doing SModcast so in the
beginning like I you know we were
figuring out what it was we didn't know
what it was and stuff and then one day I
was like oh [ __ ] this is my biography
it's my unwritten biography here I get
to tell every [ __ ] story and if you
listen all these episodes it's like the
story of my life told from beginning to
end and [ __ ] like that so yes mod cast
will be my biography and then we started
adding like other shows like first tell
em steve-dave which like were my friends
but you know I was happy to showcase
them because I thought they were really
funny and then as the podcast network
grew I realized it wasn't my biography
was this wonderful showcase and
spotlight for all the people that I've
stood beside or with who've made me look
good and I know that they are far more
talented more special have something
more to offer than I did lucky I had
luck and timing on my side I made a
movie at the right
and time and stuff like that and I've
been able to string it out to like a
[ __ ] quarter of a century career but
like if I was just left to my own
devices I would have been left in the
dustbin of cinematic history people be
like oh I think he made a movie wants
that black-and-white movie set in a mall
or something like that but because I've
allowed myself with people who are
talented and people who take me in a
different direction and take me on these
wonderful journeys my career keeps going
so it's not like me going like I'm gonna
help this person out it's me going help
myself like you know when I brought you
into fat man I'm Batman is because I
liked the show more when you were on it
I was like yeah I like talking to people
but I like when we do that and then when
we built it and rebuilt it here I was
like this this is the [ __ ] move and
stuff so I appreciate the shout out but
at the same time I'd be stupid not to
use the resources around me you know
it's like especially with all the talent
there is and the places we can go so
thanks but it's a very mutually
beneficial relationship we sucked each
other's do we do okay so that's all the
news we got mark found you the news give
it up for [ __ ] mark man now we come
to the eagerly anticipated part of the
show you're gonna get it you're gonna
get to be first [ __ ] with glee this is
the part of the show ladies and
gentlemen that people seem to dig the
best I dig it as well
but I like hearing the news more than
anything else cuz I usually learn
something but I love doing the Q&A part
of the show because people seem to get
stuff out of it I always read the
reactions later on online and stuff and
you know a lot of people out there want
to do some version of what you and I
have been lucky enough to do and here in
this format we usually don't hold back
put it on Front Street people seem to
get something out of it so that makes me
happiest books so we're about to jump
into what it was a long way of saying is
everyone's favorite part of fat man I'm
Batman the QA lady's a gentleman the Q&A
is about to begin now
we have very simple rules for our QA man
we you can ask anything you want but it
should be something that both me and
mark can answer if it's something that's
me specific or on the rare occasion
marks specific where somebody's just
like how's your mom mark or something
like that
it's best if it's a question that goes
kind of both of us something that we
could both kind of answer and do it big
think on if you do that correctly you're
gonna win some tickets man I don't know
if you people have ever been to a 40x
theater in your lives but if you haven't
you are missing out on the experience
the 40 X movie allows you to sit in the
chair that [ __ ] moves and [ __ ] and it
blows water in your face it's like
getting [ __ ] it's that good there's a
lot of movement and [ __ ] gets thrown in
your face and whatnot the movie started
and a movie happens if they if they're
on a motorcycle and they skid out you
smell the burnt rubber if it's snowing I
always used this example in the
beginning of civil war it was snowing it
snowed in the theater when I was
watching it I was like this is a miracle
and I opened my mouth tried to catch it
on my tongue and they ran and said don't
it's chemicals and so I they didn't do
that this is a fantastic experience if
you've never seen a movie in 40 X make
sure you go see it but we'll give you an
opportunity here with the QA we got five
sets of two tickets man you could go see
the 40x theater here in town is down at
LA live so these tickets will get you
into there and I imagine they'll get you
into a number of 40x theaters around the
United States but that's the one that's
closest to us we get these tickets given
to us free by the good folks at 4dx
because of Brett deacon man give it up
for the good friend of the show Brett
deacon
okay man we got five sets of tickets to
give away and we have a very eager
question ask her who's been wanting to
go for an hour man wait he's been
pinching it for an hour
JC bar proprietor here just come in
villany give it up for JC ladies and
gentlemen JC is gonna give the B the
human mic stand as we talk to my man
what's your name my friend Amy's Jose
Rodriguez give it up for Jose he's the
first question of the night what can we
do you for Jose I personally feel that
the Ben Affleck and I really have a
personal connection to Ben Affleck it's
one way to his Batman movies how are
unduly right not regulated underrated
because of Christian Bale's amazing
portrayal of Batman
he is he is unjustly maligned malign yes
that's a great word that's a great word
against Christian Bale because Christian
Bale exists no one wants to argue
against Christopher Nolan's
interpretation of Batman look we're all
maligned because Christian Bale exists
because nobody could live up to that
impossible standard the man's a genius
but why why he gives Ben Affleck such a
bad rap when he's just trying to go
against a god in the movie in a movie
obviously in a movie nine not in the
real world as far as we know yeah well
he did it no one's told me otherwise no
one told me other I saw him go against
God once in a movie called Dogma but
other than that
I made that all right but getting back
to the point the question is why has
been unfairly maligned I I think he's I
think if you think back to when Batman V
Superman came out he was the one that
actually skated he got a lot of [ __ ]
praise like therapy they they were
people going this movie's got a lot of
issues ironically Affleck as Batman is
not one of them that was my recollection
of people's reaction of BBS they had
issues with you know the tone and the
darkness and [ __ ] like that but he was
the one thing that most people agreed
was really good in the movie I I think
that a great performance can survive a
bad movie I think like I have a [ __ ] ton
of love for Rip Torn and Beastmaster
that movie's a piece of [ __ ]
but Rip Torn is killing it what a deep
cut pole that was man took me right back
to the early days of HBO in 1983 where
I'm watching it over and over
I don't think Ben Affleck's Batman well
we all do agree that in in Batman V
Superman we're like hey you know what
[ __ ] okay I'll swing with that guy
that [ __ ] scene where he takes out
like 12 guys trying to save Clark Kent's
mom spoilers Martha I didn't want to say
it but yes Martha he said it too much of
the movie is a is like a fantastic
[ __ ] do it like it is totally
serviceable everybody was on board I'd
like to see more of this and then you
get Justice League which most people did
not feel was good enough to help Booey a
performance and his performance was not
so great you like you know what that
will be blue but that [ __ ]
Batman was awesome the the the the
rising tide did not lift that particular
bit but if you can delete Christian Bale
will not Ben Affleck be much a better
character let me translate if if sorry
my drink in a world without Christian
Bale's performance to judge yes yes
absolutely
those people wouldn't be as shitty about
yes that's exactly my point that
question deserves tickets give it up for
everyone tickets
give that microphone right to him right
now well done well done
he needs that mic there you go all right
give it up Thank You Jose welcome thank
you sir
all right where are we going next JC hey
Kevin hey it's Holly everyone give it up
for Holly I actually just have something
going back to the wall there okay I have
something for you
Oh what's up it is a little token for me
and Jon Schnepp good friend of ours
ladies gentleman a much better friend of
Holly right here that's fantastic oh my
god it's him it's a cameo snip look at
that Jon Schnepp passed away while we
were all at comic-con this year and when
I was doing my whole age thing I did a
minute of silence for him and stuff
snap voice well thank you so much for
that God no worries Snape was one of us
I talked about him here I think as well
when we came back king of the sweat ease
man as much as a lot of us adored him
Holly adored him the most Holly was his
one true so it's been a really what I
can only imagine has been an impossible
month for you how are you doing it's
surreal I don't know how to describe it
any other way
but I am getting messages from them
every single day
I'll tell you guys a little weird story
actually it kind of has something to do
with you in a weird way the time we did
Fatman on Batman you and John had a
conversation about milk that went on for
quite some time yes because you I was a
big milk official yeah you were chugging
and John is a chugger okay
he would like drink all of my milk all
the time in the house we would have to
have separate milks and when he would
run out of his he would dip into mine
and all I needed mine for was tea and
cereal and at once this one time he
actually this is actually just about two
months ago he had knocked off all of my
milk and I was like okay you got to stop
doing this this is ridiculous I don't
use nearly as much as you do you got to
stop he's like all right I'm all yummy
some right now which is what he did all
the time so you ordered two more gallons
of milk from yummy and then it's an
apology he got me some Andes mints which
are my favorite chocolates and so he so
a week later I had forgotten about the
Andes mints for watching some show I
don't know and I'm looking in the fridge
for the chocolates it sounds like wow I
had those chocolates gonna gonna eat
those chocolates now and I and I looked
for him they were nowhere I was like
John where those uh those apology
chocolates go wherever those were you
know where they went need something he's
like I ate them and a week after he
passed I got a brick of Andes mints in
the mail who delivered to me that showed
up on my front door and it was what's
that I don't know I didn't know it says
Holly Payne on it so I don't know if it
was him or not but it was definitely you
know one of those moments of just like
what the [ __ ] is happening the other
thing is that he was hoarding beyond
death um he one of the funny pack just
kept coming every single day after he
passed away and one of the things that
the first things that arrived was a
comic book spinner rack the size of me
ah it's the fake kids comics yeah
exactly so I had to carry that
[ __ ] through the house and back
to his office and the things kept
showing up like a MODOK ice cube tray
mold just stuff like this was constantly
showing up but but it was it was just
you know him kind of you know saying I'm
still I'm still here you know I mean I
haven't gone anywhere that's I think it
my favorite you know I saw a lot of
tweets about schneps passing but one of
my favorite that kind of put it right on
Front Street for me was he was the only
[ __ ] who gave a [ __ ] about
Superman lives and he wouldn't rest
that's right until he figured it out
that's right yeah and it's true if
you've never seen John and Holly's
documentary The Death of Superman lives
what happened what happened it's not I
don't just say this because it's onra
and we [ __ ] love this stuff it's a
wonderful documentary if you're into our
world the world of genre the world of
sci-fi the world of comic book movies
and stuff like that world of
entertainment I think if you're just a
fan of documentaries test if you're if
you're a creative person if you're
interested in creativity period there's
something for everyone but there's the
superficial story of what it's about
which is how that movie didn't happen
the version of the Superman movie with
Nick Cage playing Superman and schnap
and Holly tracked down like [ __ ]
everybody if they even though maybe you
need to regress it yeah but he would
have sat for it they still got that
amazing footage of him dressing up in
the costume like [ __ ] that nobody had
ever seen before not even me and I
worked on the [ __ ] thing so it's an
amazing documentary if you've never seen
it and that tweet brought it home
because it's true it's like that was a
passion project nobody was ever gonna
get to the bottom that it was just
something that would have been lost in
the winds to history but you and him had
such passion for it you manifested an
amazing documentary and sat down with
people like [ __ ] Tim Burton Jon with
ears and Jon Peters I love that daka's
like for years I've been telling my
Superman story of people like John
Peters doesn't really exist does he and
then when that movie came out I'm like
look he does and all his glory I said in
500 street fights yes
oh my god I remember seeing the movie
where at the at the Egyptian the
Egyptian and I I was so elated for that
moment because the audience is like
laughing is he sitting there talking
about street fighting you know I knew I
wasn't crazy but in any event Schnepp
and Holly went forward after that and
put together a series yes yes we
actually we have six rough cuts of six
episodes of the what happened series
which is six more unmade films I can't
reveal what those films are yeah they're
good they're good I do I know as soon as
your life calms down and whatnot
that's something that we're gonna make
sure that we do for for the king of
sweat ease yeah and and I find nope I'm
imagining correctly he's in that footage
isn't oh he's all over the guy this is
his legacy this is gonna be the last
time you know we're gonna see him on
screen so there's a lot there well
there's a lot of projects he was working
on but this is gonna be the last you
know one yeah yeah we're gonna go find
that at home awesome as soon as we can
man it's it's sucked to lose him for me
and I was just an admirer it was mutual
I can't yeah he was darling but I can't
imagine what it's like for you anything
you need
we're all here for you of course thanks
Kevin
[Applause]
we love you how I take some tickets go
see a movie
alright JC where we want to go next
what's your name good sir how you my
name is David David David hey we'll give
it up for David
where you from David I'm from God's
country
Scotland ah right on man holy [ __ ] yeah
lovely lovely place in the world you
should go visit lovely I've been there
where what part of we're in Scotland
school one a well so just north of Adam
Brothers a little way little place
called the kingdom of Fife and that's
what I say and you live in a kingdom
yeah Kevin it's all - so in the kingdom
of faith and I have a son and I have
three sons and my eldest son fifteen
years old we've got this running
argument that I hope that you still can
help us out with tonight
we'll try we've got an argument on a
straight race between Superman and the
flash now I know you've got a vested
interest in the flash and wherever and
well okay I say you think I'm in the bag
for flash don't I absolutely 100% I have
worked with supergirls yeah I know you
did I hope I read it but I am a hundred
percent in Superman's camp yes my 15
year old son is a hundred percent in the
Flash's camp he would win in a straight
race the flash or Superman are they both
allowed to use their powers 100% all
right I'm gonna give this some serious
[ __ ] thought more thought than Joss
Whedon ever gave it I assure you
although I love that little button in
the movie I thought that was adorable
remember Superman reverse tank so that's
all I'm saying you know bike going Fox
that's my argument would always lean
toward if we're talking about Superman
and you're including every incarnation
of Superman that includes Superman from
Richard Donner's Superman one who
somehow has the ability to fly so
[ __ ] fast
backwards turn back time now that was
flying but that's using all these
peppers every part of God but if they're
having a race he's allowed to fly it's
not here just to eat then from Superman
standing next to flash point a tiny
flash asks the question let's race to
see who's fastest Superman's like I beat
you 10 seconds ago
ha ha like it's got the nineties so
[ __ ] fast the time jet your kid says
flash yeah it does Barry Allen because
of the ultimate universities and the
things but he can jump forward and stuff
like he totally believes that flash
would be the winner every single time I
mean there's that he gives the flash has
the ability to run so fast so you can
travel through time and dimensions as
well hmm
but here and the TV show at least and
probably in a lot of flash comics
there's always this trope of I've got to
get faster like if only you were fast
enough Barry you never hear that nobody
ever says the Superman if only you were
more super you know like immense like
he's just he's he's Jesus go ahead they
do both go back in time but um yes but
that's why I pulled my what I say is
that the Barry from TV is always not
fast enough he'll won't be fast enough
until they get to the last season and
then they're like my god Barry you did
it you know and then credits you're so
much faster yes so if it's if we're
including every incarnation of the
character then Superman could travel to
talk just like flash but flash always
needs to somehow get faster so I give
Superman the edge plus yeah plus he's
older I don't know why but for me in my
mind to that I saw the dude more
experienced could you just say on camera
cool I'm sorry what they have calls
right cool cool I'm sorry yep that's
right Superman wins call I'm sorry but
your dad is right Superman way
[Applause]
yeah baby but as a consolation prize I
must sing you a little song I heard in a
movie many years ago
beautiful beautiful as from mr.
Holland's Opus over to you mark okay you
don't remember any of mr. Holland's Opus
all of mr. Holland's Opus remember he
sings at the end he finally sings -
because he's guarding her right and he's
the musician you never got to be a
[ __ ] musician so his opus was the
class of kids that he taught who
eventually come back to the remake you
want to watch the movie again not as
much but I want to hear you tell me
about it all right what do you guys got
an answer for I have an answer because I
I think that that one of their powers is
based in in physics and science in what
can be achieved by by the use of natural
forces give or take even if one of them
is a Speed Force and the other one is
all about will Superman's powers derived
by the strength of his will he can lift
as much as he can lift because he wants
to he chooses to we can run as fast as
he can run because he chooses to he's a
being of pure will and that level of
will and Superman of all [ __ ] people
the will of a god I feel like there is
no limit to how fast or how strong or
how far he could do anything he wants to
do so I Cole I'm sorry
is right on this one awesome thank you
guys excellent job give it up from you
win tickets take them tickets how long
you here in Los Angeles
four nights you make it down Sophie man
pleasure give it up for a man
[Applause]
hey Cole is gonna be so disappointed hi
what's your name I'm Mario Cunha yes
you wish me a happy birthday Hollywood
babble-on Comic Con oh my god Cunha
cocoon ha put it in her Koon ha boom
Hakuna Matata did we make that joke
alright what is your first name Mario
Mario give it up for more did you do it
family first of all I have to say I
would have paid a hundred bucks to
follow the first guy why cuz that was
easy to follow so I saw you get your
inkpot at comic-con so Hollywood on
Babylon after you got your Inc amazing
we did where the Inc quad brothers
graces at all also shameless plug this
is our sci-fi sands bar science
sci-fi fan bar in San Jose we'd love to
have a podcast there sometimes it's in
San Jose San Jose
Dunnan San Jose's up by like where the
Sharks play exactly so that's a flight
San Jose improv you've been there before
I've been there many to see you yes and
I have driven there that's doable do you
know the way to San Jose I did once a
long time ago so obviously we've been
fans of Kevin Smith forever clerks and
everything but mark barnard and we find
you because of the podcast here and in
my facebook memories is all the articles
you've written over the years that I
didn't even know I was sharing that were
from you that you've written so I love
what you write we want both of you to
sign the Hat please okay so my question
is the way you have a geek themed bar as
well yes and now it's called seven stars
was it fills stars what is your theme
here we're trying to figure out what
JC's theme is I can't put my undergrown
it but is it a last starfighter
you're unofficially Star Wars your bar
is unofficially Star Wars officially
well I don't know if you should do that
that's awesome man so what is how long
you guys been open it were in our eighth
year we just started our eighth year
this month and here I thought [ __ ] JC
had invented the idea he came at it a
totally different direction from ours
and we send all our people that are
coming this way to come here and see
this we've been here at least 20 times
since it opened and glass man thank you
fellowship of the ball yes have you been
to seven stars JC soon [ __ ] prick man
get your ass to San Jose he knows the
way my question is as someone who's not
an entertainment business at all I've
heard you both talk about how you direct
the flash and we saw your castle walk
episode six amazing but someone who's
not in the entertainment business I'm
really curious where the showrunner runs
a timeline where the writer takes over
what he says where the director takes
over and what he does I'd like to hear
you guys explain the impact that you
have on the episodes that you write and
direct for me too oh hey now okay okay
you you've got more experience in
television than I do I can pick I can
pick up directors but go ahead I have a
bit more yeah so the way television
works is you know if I show up to work
on the first day and in the writers room
of the show there will probably be a
pilot script there will be some document
that we've all read that tells us kind
of what the show is thinking and he will
say to us all right we have 10 episodes
to tell a story where should it start
and where should it end and then we talk
for about two or three weeks about just
the broad strokes of the story we know
we want these characters in it we kind
of know we want it to end here we kind
of essentially want these two people to
fall in love and that got to kill that
guy and like the big moves is this
called the blue sky period this is a bit
of the blue sky period what could the
show be if it could be anything what
could it do if it could do anything and
after that blue sky period usually a
couple weeks two three weeks it becomes
alright here's the story you want to
tell how do we break that in two
episodes there's ten episodes then
Episode three will be this followed by
four which is this and those are just
like index cards in a wall this is the
episode in which
the prisoner gets out of Shawshank is
literally the thing on the wall and the
next episode is here's the episode where
Henry here's the thing episode six no
six and so we then say okay this is
great these feel like the right chunks
of those stories now we'll take episode
1 and say what are the dozen scenes or
so that are going to be an episode 1
it's basically working from giant to
small as macro to micro and the entire
room the entire time is throwing ideas
at the showrunner and saying what if we
did this what if we did this what if
what if in episode 4 you know Henry gets
in a prison escape in it and a gun goes
off right next was Eva and it gives him
tinnitus but what if that tinnitus is
tying back into another sound that's
kind of keyed into the rest of his life
that was my pitch that that's how I
ended up doing episode 6 because I was
like hey what if we had also talked a
lot about Castle Rock being the town
that evil was drawn to because there was
a low frequency epicentre of sound in
that town and it's a scientific [ __ ]
thing there are birds that will just
circle because they're drawn by a sound
and they will die circling over that
sound and so what if Castle Rock was
that kind of place and what if Henry was
the only person who could really hear
that sound and how would he unlock that
memory of that sound gunfire and is the
ringing in his ear and that all tie into
this whole [ __ ] thing and we'll start
explaining what the show is with that
idea so as a writer we're all doing that
we're all just what if we did this what
if we did that what if in this scene
he's standing on the top of the [ __ ]
you know gasps and Stephanie sees the
future ahead of him in this scene what
if [ __ ] [ __ ] Specter dives off a
bridge in this scene what if what if
what if that's all that that job is for
a good couple of months at least in
Castle Rock that's what it was and then
once we're all satisfied with the what
if once those boards are filled with
scenes for every episode writers go off
and write and then it's the the hard
work of sitting by yourself in a room
with your laptop and just like all right
an interior [ __ ] blah blah blah
Henry walks down the hallway and I
everything is [ __ ] scary you know
like and that's that part of the job you
finish the script you give it back to
the room to the showrunner they all read
it they all give it notes and
it's being shot and that's when you
bring in a director you will say all
right hey keV listen we think your would
be great for this I didn't do that
because I wasn't in that position to be
like I think Kevin would be awesome for
this was a baby writer on Castle Rock so
I had no real juice beyond hey I think
I'd have some decent ideas maybe they'll
be of some use but then they will hire
directors who will come in and they will
read the script and there will be like
tone meetings and say here's kind of
what the episode should feel like years
what it needs to accomplish here's what
happens the story after here's what
happens a story before here's the
emotional baton you have to carry here's
the plot threads you have to connect and
man go off and make us a TV show right
that sounds pretty accurate I've come
into the process much later like on the
CW stuff I've done the flashes and the
super girls it's it's been after the
shows have been up and running they've
figured out their seasons they've
started writing all their scripts and so
you know I'm just one of those you don't
have much input as the director you
can't really shape the show unless you
direct the pilot then it's all about
what you do but when you're coming on to
an existing show like even in Castle
Rock whoever did the pilot set the tone
for the show whoever directed Episode
five is doing variations of the pilot
essentially so for me when I get into
the process it's everything's been set
they've done all that [ __ ] and then I
get a script and they're also pretty
tight about like they don't want you to
change anything so it's not like as
director I could be like you know what
man like I don't like the gas and sip
scene like I don't want to shoot that or
rewrite something better chances are the
director has no power to make those
changes like I would say that to the
writers and the showrunner and writers
are pretty unified front and I'm sure
they'd be like all right well [ __ ] you
will get a different director like
because the writer is king in that
medium and they want the director to
execute and/or elevate their vision not
bring the
director's vision to it and stuff like
that so in when I'm involved in the
process that way
I'm just the pair of hands that's on set
going action cut most of the power lies
in their hands like when I'm done
shooting all that footage I send it back
to production and the showrunner sits
there and you know well an editor will
put it together but a showrunner is the
one gonna be like lose this keep this
losses they the showrunner is
essentially it in TV or streaming or
whatever is what the director is in film
just like everything like you've got all
the [ __ ] power everything rests on
your games on your stick good or bad so
if you [ __ ] it up everyone blames you if
you do a great job everyone [ __ ]
blames you and stuff I'm working on a
different thing now that I'm I'm in a
different end of the process where if
everything works out well then that I
would be a showrunner which would lend
more toward what I'm used to doing in
the day job as a movie maker and stuff
and we'll see if it keeps going forward
and stuff but listening to that was
helpful for me because that's I will be
if everything goes well I'll be heading
to the next step or it's like okay we
got to pull together a writers room and
unlike most writers rooms like it
wouldn't be a situation of like what
will this show be there's a map already
like that's one of the things that I was
brought out to do so I'm gonna be able
to see both sides of that equation and
it's been nice doing the CW stuff just
as an observer because you know you can
pick and choose how you would do I've
now done it enough where I can look and
see how showrunner runs a show and form
an opinion on how I would do it would I
do it that way would I do it a different
way and most of the time I'm like this
is all good maybe I would change this or
do this a little bit different so that's
been good training for if this thing
winds up happening if this thing doesn't
wind up happening there's another TV
show that I've been working on and if
that one doesn't wind up happening
there's a [ __ ] third I'm spending a
lot of place we will fund it I just need
one of them to go man so I'll let you
know as soon as it gets close and stuff
it would be cool if it goes though but
I'll find out what it'll be like to be
at the show runners yeah that'd be nice
to be able to be like this is what I had
my ideas for the story take this script
and go run with it and then watch people
hand back better versions of ideas I had
I look forward to that yeah that was a
great question
that was great give her tickets
everybody gets applause for that
question put it there the only man well
done what's your name young hammer
I'm Bart Bart Bart give it up for
[ __ ] bark man a good name from our
childhood he never here Bart
it's not telling my graffiti name I
chose it because I like you pick the
name what name they give you yeah I'm
from Burma so I came all the way from
Burma to see your show actually number
one thank you number two quit bragging
what what is you so what is your name
was your real name you Burmese name is
John okay but no one can announce it say
it again John Mookie Joe Joe Joe Joe
like it's part [ __ ] bards fair enough
what can we do you for Bart and where
are you where you from I'm from Myanmar
also known as Burma Burma where and now
I'm sorry I'm an idiot
where is Burma it's between Thai India
China it's in Asia holy [ __ ] you and
Stephanie came the farthest to see this
[ __ ] show didn't ya give it up for
him he's from Burma for heaven's sake I
think Scotland and Burma should fight to
see who gets the trophy yeah who loves
us more do it for coal
I've been listening to the show since my
first year of college since Paul Dini
episode I was a fan of clerks and dogma
and everything because there is a fan
base of Kevin's
in Burma get out of here yeah you could
miss Kevin Smith yeah and there are all
my friends they know me then you know
how they know you because I show them
the movies thank you
I have sleepover parties and I do clerks
clerks to dogma and Mallrats marathon
I've never thought of doing that myself
I'm gonna start having iboga parties as
well bite some people don't like who's
on the front end of the circle jerk when
you guys are watching all the group is
called geek amania Burma's a shout out
to you guys all of you what's it called
[ __ ] mania Burma Burma yeah so I have
two questions fire away the first
question is if mark was to write a movie
for you and play with the view s
universe toys like Randall Dante Jane
Silent Bob Loki all of those guys what
would you do and let them think about
that because that's you got a build I
wanna get but that's a great [ __ ]
question I would be curious to see what
you would do SMI yeah let's go for the
second maybe the second one is when are
you getting Neil Gaiman to do fettman on
Sandman oh god what a great [ __ ] call
yes
hopefully soon I mean I like we've done
we've been doing the show for years I've
known Neil for years going further back
that he was a voice I still like [ __ ]
giggle to this day Neil did a voice in
Jay and Silent Bob's super groovy
cartoon movie he was the butler Albertan
[ __ ] and hearing his [ __ ] like dulcet
British tones in the middle of that
cartoon while Jays making butt [ __ ]
jokes is a career-low for him but I
think I could probably get him on the
show man I just got to ask him next time
he's in Los Angeles I'll come over he's
had a very busy year because he show ran
Good Omens like he's you know he was
there doing American Gods second season
I think right now but he didn't show run
that shows based on his work
but Good Omens he oversaw personally I
think it was the first show he's ever
show run because he well he loves his
book but more importantly he was a dear
friend of Terry Pratchett the co-author
on that book so Neel was like I got to
make sure that I do Terry
justice and stuff so he's been very busy
but I saw him very briefly at IMDB when
I was interviewing people at San Diego
on the boat and stuff and we talked
about like you got to come over and
chitchat so the sooner rather than later
hopefully maybe we'd even get him to
come in to the bar that'd be [ __ ]
phenomenal and I don't I think you know
he's British so he must like bars so I
think we might be able to get him come
in too but I'm sure there's gonna be a
press swing for Good Omens probably in
the fall winter so maybe so that seems
like the most likely probably around
there man but yeah definitely because
[ __ ] I that dude inspired me as a writer
when I was kid I've said many times like
before I started my journey like before
I wasn't made clerks and stuff I the
last meal that pop culture meals that
I'd nourished myself with like carried
me for 10 years and like was all over
the work that's why there's lots of Star
Wars references and [ __ ] like that but
one of them big one was Neil Gaiman I
was a massive Sandman fan and I had
loved the book Good Omens as well I
don't get to Dogma without the existence
of Sandman and Neil's work so it would
be an honor to kind of kick back with
them and just hold forth and if we
brought him in here my god everyone
would walk out so much smarter that dude
is he just exudes writers confidence and
and fills you with a sense of that as
well like he's these good people so
great suggestion I'm gonna put that in
my head make sure it happens more recent
than not but he's right probably be
around good omen stuff you and George
Carlin and Neil Gaiman are my
inspiration to do or they're gonna make
me cry man my god that's [ __ ] great
company thank you and I met the one guy
and he was [ __ ] fantastic I'm always
happy to report that Carlin was the
goods it wasn't like oh well you know
George was George
he was just good [ __ ] people man good
dude so thank you for the company I'm
keeping them okay you okay you will have
to help me with names because I don't
quite remember these character names
Parana I would like to do a flowers for
algernon story and if you guys don't
know flowers for algernon it was made
into this movie called Charlie starring
Cliff Robertson where there was a sort
of simple-minded what would be
characterize today is like kind of
autistic janitor who was working at a
test laboratory to create and enhance
human intelligence and they test
anonymous rat called Arjuna and Al Jenna
can somebody do mazes that he could
never do before he super [ __ ] smart
and so they're like hey it works
led to give it to this simpleton janitor
and this guy becomes a [ __ ] genius or
the real legit genius can can do social
interactions like he couldn't have he
falls in love with a lab researcher it
becomes a cause to celebrate absolutely
becomes famous and everything and then
you see that the rat the bait Algernon
that they first injected with they find
him unable to do the maze anymore so
they realized that this is a temporary
effect and then by the end of the short
story anyway the Algernon dies and so
they change it for the movie because
that's far [ __ ] grimmer than you
actually want it to be but it's it's the
rise of a guy who goes from being simple
to having everything and then losing it
and knowing he's going to lose it all
and just that like I need to have a
minute of my life I need to remember
everything that happens before I can't
remember are you talking about my
biography so I want to do that story
with the the orangutan from Bob Suzanne
Suzanne the orangutan that becomes hyper
[ __ ] intelligent and realizes that
he's trapped in a man's world there's no
place left to go but by the end of it
suddenly slowly begins to drift back
into ape and forgetting all of the joys
and wonders that he spent with Will
Ferrel at his side and now you see how
we get talking gorillas in comics and
movies
man I gave you the keys to the kingdom
the first thing you thought of was like
talking gorillas all I want is to win a
best popular film Oscar and speaking of
[ __ ] I mean this is Apple Pro nothing
but have you seen the trailer for this
movie Alfa yes like nine times it I want
to see it it looks legit good if anyone
hasn't seen the trailer for it it's the
story of the first dog essentially it's
the first bonus dog story yes like it's
a story about how man met dog and these
two start hanging out and bond and make
a friendship I watched the [ __ ]
trailer I was bawling 30 seconds in as I
go home god they're gonna be friends
forever
looks [ __ ] beautiful man but it
sounds like that I thought I was gonna
get clan of the cave bear from that
minute sec no it's just a boy his dog
it's a bunch of feet right
it's the feels um so yes that that is
the thing that I would do I would love
that I would love to see that movie but
can I point out that the ending of
flowers to Algernon well Charlie the
movie Charlie with Cliff Robertson
spider-man's Uncle Ben played Charlie
you've watched him go from being simple
to being super-smart and then you watch
him lose it and it gets frustrated
because he knows he's going eventually
to be back to the place he was so he's
aware of that it's coming whereas
Charlie never was before he was given
the serum Charlie was happy and didn't
know that he was at a deficit or some
such [ __ ] so the last image that movie
haunted me still does as a kid man they
go to see him in like of the room that
he's in and the lady who was involved
with them scientist you know says
Charlie and he turns around and he has
the simple smile that he had in the
beginning of the movie and it's so
heartbreaking cuz you know it's like oh
my god now he's completely gone I only
tell you that story because there's an
ending to a movie that I made that a lot
of people like didn't like they're like
you know the movie is hard enough but
that movie ending is [ __ ] stupid
and it was the ending of tusk at the end
of tusk she goes to see him in a little
zoo and he's there and she had same
[ __ ] moment I stole from [ __ ]
charlie moment haunted me my whole life
that when I made tusk I was like I'm
doing the Charlie thing that was a great
[ __ ] answer that was a great question
give it up for our man vemana bar'ls got
bark bark from Burma goddamn play I
think the picture with you guys
absolutely gross right after I'm jealous
your hair though man yeah it's a [ __ ]
lion's mane of air man four years to
grow that wavy and glorious I remember
youth
what is this anybody do we get to keep
this or am i we meant to we keep it we
don't have to sign it what is it yeah
yeah we're a comic book coffee bar down
at Oceanside so we wanted to come up and
bring someone come up here so people can
see you on the show otherwise it wants
to give it up for the kids with a coffee
bar from Oceanside right against that
wall right there and then the camera
will see up what is the place it on your
shirt is it called panels what into the
mic what is it panels comic book coffee
bar where is it
Oceanside California give them a website
so it's panels coffee you could find us
on social media it's app panels coffee
everywhere so microphone right in comic
books and coffee yes sir
comics and coffee how dare you put those
two things together it's an awesome
experience I gotta tell ya what how long
you guys been in business about a year
or having our anniversary September 1st
[ __ ] hi what are you doing
congratulations
what do you how are you observing the
anniversary parties live music we're
gonna do some art workshops for comics
for all ages of people then we're gonna
have some local comics creators down
there for some panels [ __ ] a man and
are you guys a couple yes my fiancee the
show my name is my brother is actually
one of the owners as well he's actually
the daredevil comic that you signed
earlier Oh get out of here really yeah
the white mug but the rest of it you can
walk out with all your [ __ ] and you're
like you know some of that was congrats
and we're really pumped with the Nick
Kroll comic gotta say so
which one hey girl it's [ __ ] good
like the stories fun and stuff but her
art is just gonna send it over the moon
because it's like incredibly violent
story and her style is very like it's
impossible to some degree so it's gonna
be nice to see what all that blood looks
like drawing like that what's the
weirdest thing that's happens that you
guys have had the business oh man it's
crazy because it's comics and coffee so
we get people all the time that come
into a comic shop that don't know that
they still make comics sometimes and so
the funniest question we get it's
awesome thank you so much come on
oh yeah thank you I thought you're just
showing it to me yeah I'm like look at
this I can write my name
so what happened so people come in all
the time and say like so is this like
your personal collection right here so
they don't realize it's an actual store
but that's the coolest part because you
know so many people nowadays don't
realize though if they're if you don't
know about comic books you'd never find
a comic shop so because it's coffee and
comics we have the pulling people all
the time and introduce them to the
medium it's the best part it's [ __ ]
smart too because it like you know not
everyone likes comics but everybody
seems to like [ __ ] coffee so exactly
it gives no reason to come in what does
it look does it look more like a comic
store or a coffee store from the outside
a little bit of both honestly so it's a
lot of focus on new books new trades and
applications every Wednesday right we
wanted to focus something a little more
open less like a warehouse more like an
open coffee bar with books all over the
walls
fuckin'-a man that's awesome of a great
idea like brought to life give it up for
the kids from panels yeah thank you for
the stuff alright ladies and gentlemen
of the scum and villainy Cantina here in
Hollywood California did you have a good
time this evening if you had a good time
at all it was only because the guys
standing it this is don't forget this
yours the Seven Stars folks there's you
guys if you had a good time tonight is
only because the man standing to my left
give it up for the great Marc Bernardo
push and that is Batman I'm Batman for
this week I'm Kevin Smith I am arpan or
tune in next time same fad time same fat
channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith not everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you